guess who I saw today
yes who I saw today guess who I saw
today I mean oh my goodness that's a sound
I could sleep to live to love to everything
to and that was the song guess who I
saw today and Grammy nominated album
um linger a while there it is she is a 23 year
old Jazz sensation whose voice has been compared
to icons like Sarah Von and Ella Fitzgerald
and she is also nominated in the prestigious
Best New Artist category for the Grammys it's
as big as it gets please welcome Samara Joy
foreign
entry points into when I was doing uh
research for you was this video and
it's like the best way to get to know
you can I show it really quickly okay
all right you just found out that you were a
two-time Grammy nominee take a look foreign
so before um you even went to college you were
interested in jazz but you almost like didn't
pursue it how did like the interest and yet
the life path finally come together how did
it almost not come together right I so I grew
up in the Bronx New York I grew up in America
um in a very musical family um my dad plays bass
my my grandparents saying you know they had a
choir called to save it to Philadelphia so I grew
up around music pretty much all of my life but
um I was in some like a sort of jazz elective
towards the end of high school and I just learned
a couple of songs for the class it was nothing
major but I didn't feel the urge to pursue it
um until I realized that I had to make a
decision about college um and I was like
I don't know I want to keep music in my
life so I auditioned for a state school
here in New York called SUNY Purchase at their
great jazz studies program I got in I was like
kind of I don't want to say rock bottom but I was
just like I didn't know anything you know I was
like pretty much I felt like the only one there
who was kind of just starting really from zero
um but I'm thankful to have had you know
amazing professors and you know supportive
friends and everybody who just kind of like
I had like a crash course on everything that
I needed to know for four years graduated
in May of 2021 so congratulations thank you
and you like to fame um and a lot of it also was
through Tick Tock and I was actually curious what
is your advice for someone who is now two-time
Grammy nominated best new artist of the year and
like crushing it it was a place where you
could put yourself out there any advice to
people I would say you know social media can be
very daunting because you feel like you have to
put on a certain image you feel like you have to
you know fit into a certain box in order to like
succeed but I think Tick Tock was the one place
where I felt like I could just be myself you know
and just sing you know I I can't dance and I
can't you know do all of the stuff you know
that that's on there but I just felt like if
I'm gonna use it I want to do it my way I want
to show my most authentic self I want to share my
passion share my music and hopefully people will
gravitate toward it and they did well yeah and it
worked and is it true at the last question that
you like ROM action comedies not just rom-coms
but action in the romantic comedies yes oh my
gosh my favorite genre because like my mom she
loves like the action stuff but I'm like more of
like the the lovey-dovey person in the family
so like anything like this means war maybe a
little Never Been Kissed You know just throw it
in there you know but by the way I write like
literally you said Never Been Kissed and I was
like oh into Josie grocery because I am her yes
I'm with you I love that genre of film too
you can go after this let's hi everybody
now and up next someone in our
audience is going to go home with
a very big surprise I am so excited
about this one don't go anywhere